hey everybody my name is Joel gross and
I said I was going to talk about
functional Python for learning data
science but as soon as I started writing
the talk it kind of became stupid
itertools tricks for data science and as
I continue to became stupid inner tools
tricks but because this is PI data I
kind of wrestled it back into shape and
now it really is something like stupid
if your tools tricks for data science so
I am a software engineer at Google
before that I did data science at
several startups I wrote a book which
you can see and I'm sort of a functional
programming zealot if you have a free
hour to ask me about Haskell and I will
talk to you about it gladly
so before we talk about functional
programming for the science we talk
about what functional programming is
everyone kind of has their own
definition but generally it involves
some combination of the following things
using functions obviously that's kind of
in the name for functional programming
avoiding side-effects so we we try and
write pure functions that don't have any
kind of side effects first-class
function so we treat functions just like
any other objects we assign them to
variables we pass them into other
functions laziness we don't compute
things we don't have to
we do work kind of on demand and
immutability we don't mutate our
variables so once we try and assign to
something we don't assign to it again so
these are kind of themes that you'll see
throughout this talk and so in
particular I'm going to talk about
functional programming in Python ed in
Python 3 a lot of what I'm doing here is
really Python 3 specific and won't work
in Python 2 so I'm kind of a recent
convert to the Python 3 bandwagon so
that's my other thing I can pitch to you
about so start with there's this
operator module which has functional
versions of all the operators like add
subtract less than greater than so if
you want to use add as a function you
can import it for an operator and use a
dysfunction there's also a module called
func tools
and the most important thing to us from
funk tools is going to be partial which
does partial function application or
currying so for instance if I want a
function that adds one to a number one
way to do it is just to define it as I
define it up here add one X is return
add call down 1 and X but using partial
I can just say add 1 is the partial
function with AD where I occurring the
first argument 1 and so if you want to
pass add 1 into another function for
instance this can be a really handy way
to do it without having to define
another function and we'll be doing that
a little bit there's also a reduce which
is basically a way of folding a list of
numbers into a single number it got
stuck in func tools because Guido does
not like it because every time he sees
it he has to grab pen and paper to
diagram what's happening and figure out
what it's supposed to do this criticism
is also going to apply to almost
everything we're going to do today so I
don't tell him about this either within
Python if we want a functional we end up
talking about iterators what is an
iterator
it's something you can call next on and
get values one at a time so in Python 3
if I have a list I can call it or on it
and give this iterator and then I call
next I get the first value 1 I call next
I get the next value 2 if I get next I
get the next value 3 and I call next
when there's no more values and I get
this stop iteration exception and it's
Python so exceptions are fine we don't
sweat them that's just that's what we
expect to see when an iterator is done
you get stop iteration so typically we
don't call it err itself instead what we
do let's take a step back the nice thing
about using next is that we can generate
these values on demand and so we talked
about doing things in a lazy manner and
not doing computations when we actually
need them this is what allows us to do
that and we'll be able to create lazy
infinite sequences which we'll be using
a lot of in kind of crazy ways so
usually what you do to get iterators is
you can use these generators which are
functions that have this yield statement
in them so what does this do if you call
lazy integers and then you call next on
it it will go until it sees the yield in
order to turn that value and then it
will pause and remember where
is then when you call next again it'll
go back to where you left off and keep
going until it sees another yield and so
on so for instance if I call next on
this lead II integers it sees wall true
goes into an infinite loop yield zero
stops that I call next again it goes
back adds one to N and repeats the while
loop yields one and so on so that this
function lazy integers really returns
every integer from 1 up to there is no
up to because there's no Vegas integer
so you can take the first any and take
the next ten and you can just keep on
taking it forever and ever you could
also do generators by doing what look
like this comprehensible with
parentheses so you can define the
squares by saying x squared for X and
lazy integers or doubles two times X for
X and lazy integers when you define that
it's not computing anything it's just
defining this generator object but until
you either call next on it or pass it
into a foreign statement it's not doing
any computations then when you call next
I'll do the first one next we'll do the
second one in a particular if you use
square brackets we'll try and compute
all the lazy integers and you'll be in a
bad spot so you don't want to do that
and one way to think about these is in
terms of pipe lines so if you're using
UNIX and you want to see how many times
in my project Euler Haskell file I've
used the word prime you can cat it and
then pipe it into a graph and then pipe
it into a word count you could do
something similar in Python open the
file lazily get all the lines lazily
filter all the lines that have Prime in
them and then not lazily count them and
in this particular sort of situation you
have to be careful if you let that F go
out of scope before you actually force
the evaluation then you'll get an error
and we won't do any more of this instead
we're going to talk about my new best
friend which is itertools itertools is a
module in Python that has all sorts of
functions that are useful for dealing
with iterables and until you use it you
look at them and say I don't know why
would ever want to use that and then
after this talking to say I don't know
why I would ever want to use anything
else so
the simplest one is probably count count
takes a start and a step and it just
generates all the numbers so if you just
do count with no arguments that's base
card lazy integer so generate 0 1 2 3 so
on there's also this I slice which will
take a slice out of a sequence so you'd
say I want all the elements from 3 until
the end I went all the elements from 7
to 9 I went the first 8 elements and so
I slice will lazily do this you say I
want you know the first 20 elements but
it won't evaluate those elements until
you force it to evaluate them there's
also this function called T which is not
usually useful but what it is it's very
useful it takes one of these iterators
and it splits it into multiple copies
that remember their values so that if
you want to iterate over them multiple
multiple times you don't have to do the
computation every time it remembers
computations for you and so that can be
more efficient
there's also repeat repeat is really
simple it repeats a fixed element a
certain number of times or forever so if
you call repeat 0 that's just 0 0 0 0 0
forever
there's cycle a cycle takes something
that looks like a list and it just
cycles over the elements so if you pass
in 1 2 3
it'll give you 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
and that can be useful in a few
situations there's chain which you have
multiple Ariel iterables and you want to
run through one and then another and
then another it will just go through the
first elements one at a time then the
element 2 the second one at a time and
then probably the most difficult one
that we'll be using is accumulate
accumulate takes a sequence and it
generates all the running totals so the
first element if you pass and add as the
function the first element of the
accumulated sequence will be the first
element in the original sequence the
next element will be the first element
plus the second element in the first
element plus the second only plus the
third element but you can also pass in
other functions and in general you'll be
doing the sequence where every element
is the function applied to the previous
accumulated element plus the next
element of the original list and so
we'll be doing that to do various forms
of magic and so here's where we start
going down the rabbit hole so to start
with inner tools does not have all the
other tools that we need so we need a
few of our own
for instance we will want to realize the
first several values of the sequence so
that are we can use I slice to get a new
sequence that only has that most first n
elements and then we the list
comprehension to actually force their
evaluation to get them back in the list
so if we call it take it take ten for
some iterable it will give you the first
ten elements and compute them similarly
we want to drop function which will say
I don't want the first ten elements I
want all the rest again we just use I
slice and say given the elements
starting from n and ending it none we
want to be able to look at the first
value of a sequence in high school
that's called head here it's just the
same thing as our next function so you
just do it that way and kale will just
want to drop off the first element and
return the rest of the sequence here we
can do partial function application
that's just I want to drop the first
element so here's an example of using
partial we're also missing a function
that's called iterates iterates
given a function f in a starting point X
should give us the infinite sequence X f
of X f of f of X so every element is
just F applied to the previous element
so one way to do this is with a
generator we say to iterate F on X first
yield X so the first time you feel next
to that X then yield from and yield from
is this amazing addition in Python 3
which is basically the same as doing for
X and whatever yield X so yield from and
then we iterate F over f of X so this
works but Python is not clever about
optimizing away recursion and so
eventually you'll get tune your cursive
calls and this will blow your stack
here's a different version while true
yieldex
and then replace X with f of X so this
one won't blow the stack it has no
recursive calls it's just a while loop
but we're continually reassigning the
value of x and that's the mutation that
we're trying to avoid when we're being
like purists dogmatic functional
programmers so how can we avoid that
well we can avoid that using accumulate
and so this is my crazy functional
version we accumulate on the series
repeat X this functions are defined here
so what is repeat X repeat X is just the
sequence where every element is X and if
you remember accumulate that was the
partial sums a running total function
where it takes the previous accumulated
element the next element in the original
sequence and does some function of them
here we're saying take the previous
accumulated element ignore the next
element in the sequence and just call F
on the previous accumulated element and
so this is going to give you X which is
the first element then it will call f of
X F of f of X so this is a really pure
functional version and it doesn't have
recursion problems and it's awesome so
we're good with it so how would we use
this iterates well if you remember how
we did lazy integers before with a loop
and a yield statement here to do lazy
integers start with zero and call add
one and then call add one and call add
one so here's an original easy integers
it's very simple iterate add one
starting at zero so what one of the fun
examples when doing functional
programming is Fibonacci numbers so 1 1
2 3 5 8 and every element is the sum of
the previous two elements so here's kind
of a naive way you might write it if you
had to do a coding interview you'd say
okay if n is 0 return 1 if it is 1 or
turned 1 otherwise call fib on n minus 1
call it n minus 2 return the sum as you
know this version is really inefficient
because what I want to do fib 10
okay well that's fib 9 plus 5 859 is 5/8
plus fib 7 so that I'm computing fib 8
twice and you just get this explosion in
how many times
getting this and so you really would
never want to compute them this way so
here's another way let's just compute
the infinite sequence of Fibonacci
numbers start with a and B 0 and 1 and
then go into an infinite loop yield B
replace a with B replace B with a plus B
this is efficient it runs fast I gives
the right results and again it has all
this like awful mutation that as
dogmatic functional programmers we want
nothing to do it so this is my Haskell
version and it's very cute and it's also
pretty terrible so we say this sequence
is given by yield 1 yield 1 again and
then yield all the elements from I'm
going to map the add function across the
sequence of Fibonacci numbers and the
tail the sequence of Fibonacci numbers
so the first element I'm adding 1 the
first element of fibs second element of
fits then the second and the third so
this does the right thing but because of
the way it's constructed every time we
get to that map statement we're
recomputing the fibs again from scratch
and so if you try and take the first 35
minashi numbers using this method it
will take on my computer eight seconds
which is too long so if you remember
itertools T that's for creating multiple
memorized copies of an iterable that
will make it so you don't have to repeat
computation so I'm grateful to some
commenters on my blog who pointed this
out to me so if you do this version
yield one yield one and now instead of
making two recursive calls to fibs I use
T and assign them to variables this
version is actually very fast it takes
you know 0.2 seconds I don't know that's
actually much much less than that those
are microseconds but it feels kind of
clunky so here's another approach given
a pair of numbers
X&Y or a and B as we called them before
the next Fibonacci after them we can
represent it as the pair Y and X plus y
so this is kind of what we're doing
before with the while loop but with no
mutation this is like a pure function
that takes an input and spits out an
outfit and now we can define our
Fibonacci sequence as a generator
comprehension I want the second element
of every pair for the pairs in calling
iterate next fib starting with the pair
of 0 1 so this is like a really nice
functional feeling way of doing this and
as a side benefit it's really fast just
for fun this is the Haskell II way of
doing prime numbers which has kind of
the same flavor if I want to filter the
Prime's out of some iterable I pull off
the first element P I return in and say
that's a prime and then I take the rest
of that interval and get rid of
everything that's divisible by P so your
standard prime number sieve and so did
final Prime's you just start that with
count 2 which if you remember is the
sequence 2 3 4 or 5 going on forever so
what I call filter Prime's on that it
pulls off the first element 2 says 2 is
the first element now take what's left
which will be the numbers from 3 on get
rid of everything that's divisible by 2
and then do it again they pull off 3
grab everything sizzle by 3 5 and so
this is how you might do Prime's ok so
I'm sure you're wondering especially
people who are leaving what does any of
this have to do with data science and so
I fall back on this is kind of my
standard example k-means clustering we
have some points we'd like to group them
into K clusters and we want the clusters
to be small in some sense so here's an
example I picked some points and I said
I want 5 clusters and they're colored
according to their cluster the star is
the middle of each cluster so the way we
typically solve this problem is with an
iterative approach we choose some
k-means to start with
each point we assign it to the cluster
corresponding to the closest mean then
based on those clusters we compute a new
set of means and we just repeat this
until we get to some stopping point and
just as one caveat this implementation
is supposed to be expository not
efficient once I talked about this and
people we're kind of murmuring the
audience that what an inefficient way to
solve this problem that code would run
forever like how dare you so that's how
I dare so you might try this with a a
not functional approach so here's a
class k-means it has a constructor and
in the constructor you say here's how
many means I want I want five beans okay
I'll remember that in a variable and
I'll set up these means as just a list
of none to start with and let's say that
I I have the means then how do I predict
the cluster for a given point well this
is sort of elaborate but all I'm really
doing is saying find the index of the
mean that's closest to this point so I
start off with an infinite distance for
each of the means I check its distance
if it's smaller than the best one I've
seen so far that's the new prediction
and then I return it so nothing fancy
here how do I find the means well
I start by just picking K of the points
at random and then I've chosen a number
of iterations let's say I'll run this
ten times and that'll be good enough so
ten times I will do the following assign
each point to its closest mean so just
assign point I to whatever the
prediction is based on those meats and
then compute new meats so figure out
what the clusters are based on those
assignments and compute the mean of each
of those clusters and I repeat that the
means will go somewhere so if I do this
I start with a hundred points in the
unit square K means five I fit the model
in those points and I do the predictions
I can plot those and get the same graph
I showed you before
so what would it look like to do this in
a more functional way let's start with
we use a function instead of a class so
we have a function k-means which takes
the points and the k and the number of
iterations and we want this function to
return us what are the means of the
clusters that we get for these points so
we start by picking K the points at
random same as before and now for each
iteration we say the means equal the
result of some function we have a ridge
yet called new means new means takes the
points and the means and returns the
next set of means so this is a
functional feeling way of doing it but
again we have this variable means that
we keep reassigning to and keep
reassigned to and keep reassigning to as
dogmatic functional programming zealots
we don't want to mutate like that so
instead of thinking about a k-means we
can instead think about k-means --is
which was the best name I could think of
but basically as we go through this
process we generate a set of means and
then each iteration we generate another
set of means and then the next iteration
we generate another set of means and so
I think of all these sets of means as
means is and so instead of writing a
function to generate means we can write
a function to generate means it's okay
so this is kind of a more crazy
functional approach given a set of
points and given K we're going to return
an infinite sequence of means --is okay
so the initial means again we just start
with pick K of the points at random and
now we're just going to iterate partial
new means points on initial means huh
what the heck does that mean
okay so partial new means points or a
partial is partial function application
our points are never changing like we
pass them in to this function so it's
fine to carry them to make a new
function and once you kerley those
points in partial new means points is a
function that map's a previous set of
means to
setter means and if you remember iterate
takes a starting point X call it's f of
X calls f of f of X so if you call
iterate on that function that map's old
means two new means you give the initial
means as a starting point you're
generating the lazy infinite sequence
that the initial means you gave it the
next set of means the next set of means
the next set it means the next set of
means the next set of means and so on
forever so if you want to run it for ten
iterations you say the means is our take
ten from the K means this function if
you want to run it till it converges
well then you just say the means azar
until convergence of that infinite
sequence and so why is this interesting
well wonder is an elusive thing is that
once we generate these means is we can
look at them and see how is this
convergence happening and what's going
on every step of the process not just
what are the five means that got spit
out at the end but how do those five
means happen so how would you run an
iterable until convergence one way to do
it is just to remember the previous
values so previous is none go to an
infinite loop pull the next value off
the iterable and if it equals the
previous value we want to stop so you
raise that stop iteration exception
otherwise you yield the value and then
you set previous back to the value but
again as dogmatic functional programming
zealots we don't want to be reassigning
value and reassigning previous all the
time so another way to do this is to use
accumulates I will say to do an iterable
until convergence we accumulate iterable
with no repeats as the sum function
where no repeat is simply given the
previous value and the current value if
they're equal you raise the stop
iteration exception and if they're not a
return the volume so start with the
first value take the second value with
the first accumulated value which was
the first value if they're the same
if they're different you make the second
value your next accumulated value and
then you keep going you can also do
something similar if you had
floating-point numbers and you want to
run this until they get really close
okay well then we can do it until nearly
convergence just give it a tolerance and
accumulate by doing instead of a until
they're the same function to do within
tolerance function meanwhile we sort of
punted we still need a new means
function but that's not hard we do our
science which is saying for each point
find the closest index of the old means
we do the clusters by saying for each
index find the points that are closest
to that index and then we just compute
the mean of each of those to find the
closest index we did this before minimum
distance is infinity iterate over the
means and for each one check the
distance if it's smaller and make that
our assignment the in return our
assignment but again we're mutating so
how can we do this in a more functional
way okay so here we find the closest
index by just saying let's create the
list of distances using list
comprehension and return bin of
enumerate distances enumerate at the
index so enumerate distances turns them
into a pair 0 first distance 1 second
distance 2 third distance and passing it
this key function that says we want to
find the minimum based on the second
value but it will still return the
parent then we want the first value of
that parent which will be the index so
that's a more functional way of writing
closest index squared distance is very
simple it's just summing up the squared
differences of the elements I mean
cluster mean is also pretty simple you
basically do the index wise sums and
divide by the number of points so eyes
on the side I just wanted this trick a
few days ago but matte pot lid will make
animations for you all you need to do is
import animation and define a function
animation frame which takes a frame
number and does something matplotlib e
that corresponds to that frame so get
the data based on the frame number plot
the data
and if you have imagemagick installed
you can write them out as animated gifts
so for instance here I pick 500 random
points the unit square I compute the
list of means is that runs until
convergence and I pick five colors and
kay here's five and so what is my
animation frame look like well for frame
one I want the first or the one element
of the means is series compute the
assignments and the clusters plot the
clusters plot the points and color the
points so if I do this you can actually
see here is the sequence of means as it
goes in converges and the points get
recolored you can kind of see what's
happening that it starts off somewhere
random but eventually it gets to a point
where one clusters right in the middle
and four clusters are right in the
corners which is probably what you'd
expect so here's a different random data
set where the x coordinates are 0 1 2 4
5 and the Y coordinates are a normal
variable I couldn't really tell you why
I chose this but I did and again you can
see that the means kind of move around
kind of easy to expect but it's kind of
neat and fun to watch all right
so how else can we apply this to data
science well another place where this
turns out to be pretty interesting is
gradient descent a lot of models that we
use involve taking minimums and things
taking maximum of things solving
optimization problems so gradient
descent is where we minimize a function
by computing the gradient the vector
partial derivatives and taking small
steps in the opposite direction for
example let's say you want to find out
the minimum of some function where it's
just the sum of the squares of all the
elements so you pass in a list of
numbers and it's the sum of the squares
now being data scientists we know that
that minimum is going to be when all the
numbers are zeros but let's pretend that
we don't know that and kind of proceed
so if you remember your calculus the
gradient of this function is just two
times each coordinate so now we need to
say well how do we take a gradient step
well to take a gradient step we need to
know a few things one is the gradient
function the second is a parameter alpha
which says how big do we want the step
to be and the third is the point X which
is say which is the point we're starting
from so starting at the point 1 1 and
given that gradient function I defined
in the previous page and given a step
size to say point 0 1 where do I end up
after taking that gradient step so I
just say I'll zip together the points
and the gradient because I want to move
each coordinate corresponding to that
point and I to each point X IJ I add
that factor alpha times the J's
component of the gradient gradient step
is a nice pure function and suggestively
if you take it for a given problem we
might want to keep DF the gradient
function fixed and alpha fixed and if
you Curie those then you have a function
that maps from a point to the next point
which should seem kind of familiar
because you can just use a iterate and
there you've written a gradient descent
so what is this gradient descent doing
and saying let's iterate that function
which takes a point and maps it to the
next point on the starting point so you
get the starting point you get the next
gradient step the next gradient step the
next gradient step the next gradient
step so these this is six lines of code
and it would probably be four lines of
code if I use a smaller font which I did
not do because I care about your
people's eyesight but this is basically
a working implementation of gradient
descent right here so if I give it a
that function which is the sum of the
squares
started a random point and say run it
400 steps and show me every xx value
well the first value is just somewhere
random 0.35
189 B&T that it very quickly moves to
points that are very close to zero so I
can use the same animation trick and say
you know what I want to run gradient
descent on just two variables x squared
plus y squared starting at 50 random
points so i Function define a random
point i grabbed this giant map on the
list of colors and I say I'm going to
get a length 25 path for each of 50
different points so for each of 50
different points
I run gradient descent 25 steps and I
store that as a path and then I just say
I want to animate this so in the end
frame I'll draw the nth step for every
one of these points and so you can see
that no matter where they start they
always go right toward zero as you would
hope so nothing too exciting we could
have solved that ourselves so here's a
slightly more complex function it's a
exponential negative x cubed over 3 plus
X minus y squared has a minimum at x
equals 1 y equals 0 and a saddle point
at x equals negative 1 y equals 0 and so
if I do the same to this one you get a
little more interesting picture you can
see all the points running off along the
gradient lines but I'm not really here
to talk about calculus I'm here to talk
about data so for any of that let's take
one side step which is a stochastic
gradient descent so in that previous
example we were just trying to minimize
a function of a single point but when
working with theta a lot of times we're
saying let's find the parameters that
minimize some error function across our
data and a lot of times those error
functions are additive so that error is
the error on the first point plus the
error on the second point here on the
third point and so one approach is to
use gradient descent on the sum of the
error function to find the optimal
parameters but a lot of times that's
slow and so what you do is you just take
a gradient step on one point at a time
and you do that for each point
um and so here our data is fixed and so
if we carry them we're trying to find an
optimal value of some parameter beta so
this is a function for taking a
stochastic gradient descent step it's
not that different from the previous
function the only real difference is
that instead of just having an X it has
a previous beta and then also a point
that we want to take a step from so we
take the point which is an XY pair that
we want to take the step from a get an x
and a y out of it and we take the same
gradient step based on the gradient and
then to implement stochastic gradient
descent it's just these two simple lines
of code which are not that simple so
what is this code doing um so if you
remember chainé chainé takes one
iterable returns all the values from it
and then takes a second interval and
returns all the values from it
afterwards so this chain I have right
here starts with a list containing just
beta zero
so its first element will be beta zero
then after that it calls cycle on zip X
Y zip pairs together corresponding
elements so the first element of zip X Y
is the first Exped with the first Y the
second element is the second element of
X paired with the second element of Y
and cycle will just repeat those over
and over and over again so that X Y is
the sequence starting with beta zero
then X 0 y 0 x 1 y 1 x 2 y 2 until you
run out of points and then starts over
again x0 y0 x1 y1 x2 y2 ok so why would
you want to do that well if you Curie
the stochastic gradient descent step
function that way it becomes a function
of previous beta and XY I so
that's basically our partial sum again
where we say the previous value is a
beta next value were picking off is an X
& Y pair I take those and combine them
to find a new vector of parameters and
so this will give us an infinite
sequence of betas that get better and
better for minimizing or error
so in particular we going to PI this
still linear regression I'm sure you're
familiar with the linear regression
model y equals x beta plus some error
term so here X is just a constant value
and then also a random number
hundred points Y we're going to we're
going to set it up so that it really is
a linear relationship so fixed constant
of negative 5 plus 10 times the second
coordinate and then plus some random
noise and so to predict with this model
you just say that's the first coordinate
of X which is 1 times the first
coordinate of beta plus the second
coordinate of x times the second
coordinate of beta so very
straightforward with the teach you in
stats 101 and so we typically do this
using a least squares estimate so
finding trying to minimize the squared
errors so the error is just the
difference between the prediction and
the actual value the squared error is
the square of that and the squared error
gradient is just a tiny bit of calculus
which I'm not going to go through but
you can do for fun calculus is fun so
how would I apply this to cancer Grady
to send to linear regression well here's
my data set I start with a totally
random beta 0 so just random value the
first coordinate random value for the
second coordinate and then for the
results I just pick a number of steps
and generate the infinite sequence of
betas generated by running stochastic
gradient descent using that squared
error gradient function on X Y beta 0
and a small step size I take the results
and animate them just by plotting the
regression line so the regression line
goes through those two points and so you
can watch here are the regression lines
that get generated by the
to cast a gradient descent process which
is kind of a hypnotizing and fun to
watch although not more fun than it fits
and so what is the moral of this story
itertools is awesome laziness is awesome
infinite sequences are awesome and
Maplin matplotlib animation is awesome
so that's it thanks for coming
check out my Twitter check out my book
here's a code if you want to buy it from
we're adding at 50% off the code for all
this is up on my github right here and
if you do anything cool with it
I would love to hear about it and if you
have any questions I think I have a
couple minutes yeah
tell me more about which part of it is
not intuitive it's not intuitive it's
good to compute values lazily it's not a
- - that you don't to mutate variables
it's not intuitive that you that was a
very popular movie right um it's a good
question um so I'll tell you what I tell
everyone learn Haskell the Vernon High
School is totally warped the way that I
write Python as you can very clearly see
Haskell is like the gateway drug to
functional programming I think that
coming at this from like a purely kind
of Python or Python C++ Java background
it's harder to appreciate a lot of these
things where if you sit down and do
Haskell or to a lesser degree like Oh
camel or closure or some of these other
more functional languages Scala F sharp
appreciate it more
there's that everytime was the program
from house you know it's all we go
so so I sort of agree with you in the
sense that probably my biggest gripe
against python is it's not typed I sort
of disagree with you because closure is
not typed and it's a very popular
functional language right to use what um
it's a good question I've never worked
much of a scythe on but it's c-types
know Python types right yeah and it's
not and it's not going to you the power
of like a real you know type system with
Union types and things like that yeah
so one I wouldn't say that it
necessarily fare as well with any
designs I showed you I think it's
interesting to apply these algorithms I
showed to you and then it makes you know
cute animations and so I haven't tried
it with any others those are the ones
that I came up with for the talk my
suspicion would be the same that you
know pretty much anything where you're
doing an iterative process like that
treating it as this lazy infinite
approach is an interesting way to
approach it and will give you
interesting visualizations and more
understanding into the process than
something that just spits out the final
values but would you actually want to
build your production Python code this
way probably not yeah in the back
what do you mean by building your own
classes
I would say that I don't think I'm
constructing classes and like carrying
attributes around with them is something
that's really core to functional
programming I think of this small
functions aspect as being more core to
it so
sure so-so laziness is really nice
because one you get kind of efficiency
gains because you don't compute things
you don't need to and two it enables
some really interesting things for free
for instance in Haskell if you ever do
dynamic programming you don't have to do
any work for it you basically say here's
an array with my values and because of
laziness you know the first time I need
a value from this value from the array
if I define it as depending these other
values the dynamic programming happens
for free in terms of the immutability a
couple of things one a immutable code is
generally considered to be easier to
reason about once a variable is assigned
you know it's going to have the exact
same value you don't end up with things
like race conditions because no one's
modifying the variables it makes things
like concurrency and distribution a lot
easier because think about all the
complexity you get when you're trying to
like synchronize things right when you
have immutable variables you don't have
to synchronize anything so you're never
modifying anything so I think people
would say that's one of the huge gains
you get